the journey to the bottom of the
internet this is the web c right now
you're located here in the surface web a
part of the World Wide Web which is
available to the general public let's
dive a little deeper down to the Deep
Web this part of the Internet isn't
visible in search engines like Google
access to deep websites is only possible
via a different URL or IP address this
is where your Webmail cloud storage and
any password protected pages are located
if you dive to the very bottom then you
will find yourself on the dark web
getting onto the dark web is only
possible with the help of a special
software that gives the user complete
anonymity the Internet space without
laws censorship or responsibility for
one's actions can be used for good or
bad just visiting the dark web isn't
considered an offense in itself however
for example when buying illicit Goods
the user will be liable under the law
don't break the law on the dark web
better to subscribe to samsup to learn
more interesting things